HOURS...
MASKS ARE BACK FOR EVERYONE
INDOORS.
THIS -- AS STATE LEADERS TRY TO
GET A GRIP ON RISING CORONAVIRUS
CASE NUMBERS AND THE NEW DELTA
VARIANT.
((BRIAN LOFTUS))
FOR STAYING WITH US HERE AT
4:30.
I'M BRIAN LOFTUS.
((CHRISTIAN CAZARES))
AND I'M CHRISTIAN
CAZARES.
WE BEGIN WITH HECTOR MEJIA...
NEAR "SPRING MOUNTAIN" AND
"VALLEY VIEW"...
WITH A LOOK AT HOW LOCAL
BUSINESSES ARE ADJUSTING TO THE
((HECTOR MEJIA))
BUSINESSES LIKE THIS ONE
-- PARIS BAGUETTE -- ARE LEFT TO
IMPLEMENT THE NEW REQUIREMENT
STARTING AT MIDNIGHT.
THIS IS WHAT IT MEANS FOR YOU AS
A CUSTOMER.
YOU'LL HAVE TO WEAR A FACEMASK
BEFORE YOU GO INDOORS.
IT DOESN'T MATTER IF GOT THE
CORONAVIRUS VACCINE.
C-D-C'S UPDATED GUIDELINE FROM
TUESDAY, SAYING 'PUT YOUR MASK
BACK ON' -- IN PUBLIC INDOORS --
IF YOU'RE IN AN AREA WITH A
HIGH TRANSMISSION RATE.
A HIGH ONE.
ACCORDING TO C-D-C DIRECTOR
ROCHELLE WALENSKY, VACCINATED
PEOPLE COULD SPREAD THE DELTA
VARIANT MORE EASILY THAN
PREVIOUS VERSIONS OF COVID-19.
OVERRIDE CLARK COUNTY'S MANDATE
FROM JUST 2-WEEKS AGO, WHICH
ONLY REQUIRES EMPLOYEES TO WEAR
A MASK.
THE NEVADA RESTAURANT
THEY'RE WAITING TO RECEIVE
ADDITIONAL ENFORCEMENT GUIDANCE
FROM OSHA...
RESTAURANTS ARE FOLLOWING
THROUGH.
PLACES LIKE PARIS BAGUETTE JUST
HOPE CUSTOMERS ARE AWARE AHEAD
OF TIME:
((JEANNE RODRIGUES,
RESPECT EACH OTHER AND WE WANT
TO PROTECT EACH OTHER WE MUST
WEAR A MASK.
WE'RE GOING TO ASK RESPECTFULLY
IF THEY
DO NOT WEAR IT.
ISSUES YET.
HOPEFULLY WE WON'T ))
((HECTOR MEJIA))
THE MANDATE ALSO APPLIES
TO RESORTS AND CASINOS.
EARLIER THIS WEEK, THE NEVADA
GAMING CONTROL BOARD ISSUED THE
SAME GUIDANCE.
CASINOS MUST ALSO PUT UP SIGNAGE
ABOUT THE CHANGE.
HERE, THIS BAKERY KEPT THE MASK
REQUIREMENT FOR EMPLOYEES EVEN
WHEN IT WASN'T A REQUIREMENT.
REPORTING NEAR SPRING MOUNTAIN
AND VALLEY VIEW HECTOR MEJIA 8
NEWS NOW.
///
((CHRISTIAN CAZARES))